[музика]
1 вересня кожен вчитель зустрінеться у
класі зі своїми учнями та їхніми
індивідуальними історіями хтось
пропустив навчання бо перебував на
окупованих територіях хтось неповноцінно
навчався дистанційно хтось багато
припускав через постійні переїзди
тривоги відсутність електрики та
інтернету з чого ж починати новий
Навчальний рік у таких умовах з нового
матеріалу на першому ж уроці з
повторення вже вивченого чи може з
діагностики того як учні засвоїли все що
вивчали минулого року
правильна відповідь очевидна перш ніж
вивчати нове варто дізнатись як учні
володіють матеріалом які вивчали раніше
Та на що звернути увагу при повторенні
або додатковому опрацюванні Визначте як
увесь клас та кожен окремий учень та
учениця засвоїли матеріал за попередні
два роки навчання допоможуть
діагностичні тести на платформі
всеукраїнська школа онлайн розроблені
проєктом уряду Канади sorge спільно із
міністерством освіти і науки України
діагностичні тести - це інструмент для
планування роботи вчителя на початку
навчального року вони допоможуть
зрозуміти як працювати з класом загалом
і кожною дитиною окремо чи потрібно
повернутися до вивчення якихось тем або
ж одразу переходити до вивчення нового
матеріалу як працюють тести на практиці
запитаєте ви проходили тест на ми
збиралися у цим класом у синьому центрі
за комп'ютерами у нас був сайт ми на
нього всі
разом зайшли проходили тест з різними
завданнями
вийшло не все звичайно були деякі нюанси
Але так я зрозуміла які помилки мені
треба буде відправляти І до чого
прагнути Для мене було дивно Звичайно що
діти не знали ну саме на цій темі
зробили помилки я не чекала
лікування
[музика]
в спокійній манері вони не хвилювалися
проходили по мірі того як вони розуміли
текст були прогалини у них в знаннях за
сьомий клас тоді коли він почалася війна
і ми працювали на дистанційному діти
були в нервовому стані
десь мабуть у вересні жовтня думаю
проведу ще раз цей тест
з тими ж дітками з якими я проводила щоб
побачити чи є прогрес чи нема прогресу
якщо немає прогресу то можливо
повернемось точкову то якихось моментів
щоб вони розібралися переживали що може
пройду дуже погано але вийшло Ну
нормально в середній рівень Після
перегляду відео і розбирання з
вчителькою Ми зрозуміли цю тему і тепер
краще її знаємо і не помиляємось тож
Оксана та Діана вже готові до початку
навчального року з учнями підготуйтеся і
ви